j'ai vraiment pas chômé ces derniers
notamment avec tivo de la chaîne
monsieur qui on a lancé un nouveau
podcast qui s'appelle une nouvelle
chaîne youtube slash podcast qui
s'appelle actions que vous invite
vraiment aller voir si vous avez aimé
notre collaboration sur l'utilitarisme
vous allez adorer axiaux quand on fait
des matches on a le sentiment que les
les objets mathématiques existe fâche
pas comme ses voeux ce qu'on m'a dit +
tout le temps non on était vraiment un
tuyau nice tu vois moi je suis arrivé
aujourd'hui un fois où je pense que le
le snes seule chose qui existe vraiment
même si elles existent pas c'est la
machine de turing
c'est l'information aux fesses
d'information et à le traitement de
l'information
moi je pourquoi pas donc c'est vrai
passé ses revers à ce que je disais tout
à l'heure c'est le fait que tout
l'univers peut être simulé par une
machine de turing
du coup tu peux te demander si
finalement l'univers du coup à plus
d'existence que la machine de turing
qu'ils assimilent puisse éclairer le jeu
vous d'accord transgenre de genre de
position ça te plairait je pense greg
egan enfin se sentent sans spoil et le
truc qui tourne autour de ça axiome
c'est un peu de casse tout ce qu'on fait
c'est on part de vidéos youtube qui sont
sortis récemment les vidéos qu'on a
adoré et on en parle parce que c'est
juste des coups de trique et puis
souvent on va essayer de toucher de
d'apporter une petite touche un peu plus
mates ou un peu plus philo discuter
autour tout ce qui nous inspire autour
de cette vidéo on a adoré et surtout on
va faire ça de façon très informelle
alors on prépare très peu de choses
finalement et puis en bus n'ont pas on
se laisse divaguer
et ça ça contraste pas mal avec les
vidéos de nos chaînes respectives ou
bien souvent on va bien bien travaillé
la vidéo on va écrire et réécrire le
script on va remonter au tournage c'est
assez catastrophique train et les
phrases que tu auras pt 5 et 10 fois
voire plus
et puis après au montage il ya beaucoup
d'éditions et du coup finalement ce qui
ressort des vidéos dans le format
standard
c'est que les vidéos semblent pas si
vrai c'est l'impression que c'est plus
vraiment moi qui parle ça c'est un truc
quand 4
travailler c'est pas mon moi naturel et
c'est très très bien puisque c'est
beaucoup mieux que mucha que j'ai envie
de dire merci à idéaliser des mois mais
c'est un petit peu dommage aussi parce
que ça manque de cette réflexion naturel
intuitive instinctive et de la
discussion qui sont finalement des
parties très intéressante de la
réflexion de l'acte de faire des
mathématiques ou de la philosophie et
c'est ça que je trouve ça intéressant
dans l'action que j'ai vraiment voulu
faire
axi'home c'est que on voit en train de
discuter d'échanger et de réfléchir sur
des sujets qu'on ne maîtrise pas
forcément entièrement je trouve que ça
ça quelque chose d'intéressant
par ailleurs le fait d'avoir un format
plus comme ça ça nous permet de plus 10
vagues et puis peut-être parler de
choses plus d'actualité ou séparés des
trucs qui nous intéresse
particulièrement et qu'on a finalement
peut être pas le temps de traiter dans
nos chaînes respectives
en fait le truc qui est intéressant ce
genre de choses c'est que ces genres de
voileux des banques ça et tout ce qui se
passe avec les banques ce genre de
position sur lesquels on a beaucoup
d'idées nismo politique pourrait dire
clairement clairement et
et en même temps c'est des trucs
auxquels on ne comprend rien le la
plupart des gens qui ont des réactions
épidermiques vis-à-vis de tout ce qui se
passe avec les banques etc
objectivement il je pense qu'en général
ils comprennent pas ce qui se passait
quand on voit ces vidéos là on se rend
compte à quel point on connaît pas bien
du tout les mécanismes qui a derrière et
c'est donc ce fou qui sont vraiment
utiles ces vidéos pour cette raison là
pour me dire c'est même pas à hisser le
nice et pas les joueurs à hisser le jeu
mais c'est déjà même avant de lire le
jeu et si le comprendre c'est hier et
est un jeu comme le jeu de l'économie et
de la finance déjà c'est un jeu qui est
extrêmement difficile à comprendre
du coup difficile aïe je pensais me
faire des gens qui haïssent finances ne
savent pas ce qu'ils haïssent au fond
puis pour tout vous dire
j'adore thibault rigueur de logicien du
coup c'est quand même un énorme pied
pour pouvoir parler avec lui
à l'occasion de ce podcast action et ça
s'entend je pense dans notre podcast
fondé le plaisir que mon âge quand ça a
parlé ensemble
si vous aimez pas forcément format
youtube pour pouvoir écouter ce genre de
chose si vous préférez l'écouté en
podcast en faisant du sport ou
en vous baladant les eût été trop
comment dans les transports sachez que
axiom est aussi disponible sur itunes et
sur google plaît vous tranquillement
nous écouter en allant au travail dans
la voiture où jeanne s'est trouvée ou
encore donc à aller voir axiome dites
nous ce que vous en avez pensé pensez
aussi à le lac est à la fois sur youtube
mais aussi sur itunes le choix que c'est
important pour le référencement est
désolé de pas à sortir des vidéos du
format standard c'est son éthique
je prends aussi des vacances à caen il
faut particulièrement à priori et je
dois être quelque part au népal dans les
montagnes si tout se passe bien